have you ever had a difficult time with
an actor where you're just like I do not
get along with this guy is giving me a
hard time this is difficult of course
and what do you do
well I think
you know first of all you look around
you're like it's not me right
I'm not the here and then you
just try to it's just same it's actually
the same thing as what we're saying like
you're just like okay so here's the
problem what are the solutions what are
what are the tactics we can use and
you'll be like okay in this case you
know do we do we have to fire the person
do we or do we just have to fire anyone
before oh yeah sure you have
um yeah I mean uh if you're talking
about like an actor during a shoot yeah
there was one
uh situation I was involved in so more
indirectly where the actor was being
inappropriate you know a couple times
couple that where somebody was being
inappropriate we're just like that has
to be the line sorry
and you have to and we had to let fire
the mid shoot it was someone you knew
someone you liked at first or someone
you or something no not really someone I
didn't know well but somebody like that
the one that I'm thinking of right now
we were doing a TV show and an actor
came to do a relatively small part and
but was like uh being super
inappropriate with women on set and and
we all talked and very quickly we're
like we just got it cut bait right here
you know right and uh
but you know normally if an actor is
difficult you're not going to fire them
but you're going to try to just you know
talk to them and say hey you know what
you're doing is affecting everyone else
and can you not do that you know or or
don't just hang out in your trip why
would I do that David why would I do
that right well I mean I know you're
that guy you're the one difficult I've
never never
um I always do what they say
but it's just you know I don't think
film making is different than any other
workplace challenge you know somebody's
doing something difficult you gotta deal
with them and figure it out and try to
be understanding but also
eyes on the prize of what we're all
trying to get done